you guys know what rose battle is
so like is that what you're talking
about with like uh
what uh what's the kid's name david
lucas does yeah david lucas does it sure
um but like so
mainly known like start at the comedy
store um as
tony hinchcliffe hinchcliffe has done it
a bunch of times and has judged it a lot
um but yeah he's a roaster obviously
jeff ross is a big part of it he's the
one that got the show on comedy central
but basically two comedians go head to
head talking [ __ ] on each other right
and then the audience decides or judges
decide who wins and
i kind of fell into doing that in a
really backwards way where i never i saw
i used to go to the show and watch it i
was like this is insane the energy's
out off the hook people at a normal
comedy show will laugh
they might hit the table a little bit
they might clap they might woo at roast
battle
people were slamming the [ __ ] walls
when a joke hit
they would chop his [ __ ] head off
and i was like this is nuts dude and
this is happening tuesday night at
midnight so i was like this is how did
tuesday become the best [ __ ] night of
the week this is incredible
so i started doing it and very quickly
realized that i was
good at it um i was a good joke writer
and so
for over over a year i was the number
there's rankings right yeah top 50
rankings i was number one for over a
year
and i started to get bored because the
the analogy that i always use is like
i was really good at mario kart as a kid
it was really good i played like all the
time as my favorite video game
but i was always in the lead so the only
thing i would ever do was just toss a
banana peel behind me
and just keep trying to be in the lead
but it's not fun to be in the league
it's fun to chase
you want someone ahead of you that you
can be a gun in for so i started
thinking of all these ways where it's
like
how can i make this how can i like not
set myself
up to lose but how can i just increase
the difficulty level and change the game
and so i had a title bout against my
friend pat barker and this is like
november 2016
and i was out at this festival and i was
like dude i'm gonna
[ __ ] battle wearing this and my
friend that's a huge
my friend jeff chung who loves the show
was like do it like
[ __ ] yeah do it so you're just handing
him ammunition
exactly well that's the way i looked at
it right i was like i'm gonna go out
there like an
animal and i went out there in a trench
coat had
uh with electronic music playing and i
have this and i had all my friends like
throw glow sticks at me from the
audience and [ __ ] as soon as i dropped
the trench coat
and i'm standing there wearing this
unitard
that is so form-fitting and this blue
glow-in-the-dark tail that i put lights
on
and i and everyone was like what the
[ __ ]
is this because everyone knew who i was
like i've done this
so many times and pat barker
was is such a good joke writer we're
still very good friends he
was flabbergasted he had no idea what to
do
and i threw him off so because i also i
wasn't talking like this
i was like oh it's pat barker everyone
look at him fat porker what's your name
again like doing this like stupid voice
and i i beat him and
people didn't expect me like he didn't
expect me to and
even jeff ross was like pat take a
second just [ __ ] look at him right
now just
stop don't worry about your jokes look
at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and what he's wearing right now and
people thought
half the community was like that was the
most brilliant thing i've ever seen in
rose battle
you just leveled up what we're allowed
to do here and half the people were like
you cheated that wasn't you and i was
like 100
that's actually and what i realized is
that's the most [ __ ] me
i've ever been on that show yeah i was
just having fun
and being silly there was no aggression
or anything like that
and then right after i did that jeff i
got a call from comedy central literally
a month later saying that i was going to
be on season two of rose battle like i
was one of the 16 people selected
to go to the main show and that was this
moment where i was like okay so i do
this
thing two months later i'm on comedy
central
i'm gonna do whatever the [ __ ] i want
from now on and i'm gonna start
incorporating all this silly world [ __ ]
that i play that people don't really
know about into
my comedy and i don't go on stage all
the time like wearing that [ __ ] like the
really extravagant
costumes like what i wear on agt and
stuff like that that's very much like
just for that
but i will go on stage wearing like you
know kimonos and things and just like
and i was scared for a long time to do
it i was really scared because i thought
how is anyone going to take me seriously
if i'm wearing this [ __ ] and what i
realized is
people actually find me more authentic
and more
genuine because even if you wouldn't
wear this you're looking at a person who
very much knows who they
are and is very comfortable with
themselves so you listen to them because
you're like okay well whatever this
guy's doing
he knows who he is so he's coming from a
place
where of truth and that's everything in
comedy
once and that's when i figured out like
i can do whatever i want i can be
whatever i want
as long as it comes from my heart and
then
bam from that day on i was like this is
game
game over everybody wow i'm running i'm
running order the kimonos now
[Laughter]
but yeah dude it was such a defining
moment for me and
yeah and and then it also though for the
show
because it also like if you watch season
two of roast battle
every single person on there is pretty
much you know some couple people wear
some fun outfits and stuff
but i was like i'm gonna play a
different game here and this is gonna be
you know i showed people that like it
doesn't have to be two fat guys wearing
flannel calling each other rapists like
we can do better than this guys
and so yeah i think of the show i just
think of like how do you make the show
better
and the more entertaining i am the
better the show is that's incredible
so what is like the is there a different
mindset or preparation when it comes to
like roast battles versus like regular
stand up
yeah it's it's so different because like
rose battle is so
specific like you know if i you know
if i look at you guys i have to start
really like looking at you okay
did they remind me of anybody like
that's why i dropped like jj abrams if
he flunked out of skateboarding you know
honestly you look like if colorado
opened a meth dispensary
and i just you know it's
just one of those quick i have to kind
of just i look at you and i sum you up
as quick as possible
but then what really good roasters do is
you learn about the person i would start
researching you i would listen to your
podcast i would figure out little tips
that other people would have no idea of
knowing because then i can make it even
more personal
and the jokes are very specifically
catered and the whole thing is you want
them to hit
hard and you want them to be fast for
the most part like word economy is
everything
make it as short as possible but
stand up is totally different than that
because you're not writing about a
specific person well you are i mean
yourself
a lot but your and your relationship to
the world but what rose battle did for
me
is it made me go every i need to so have
so many more jokes in my stand up
like i don't ever wanna if i say a line
the next line has to be
a joke and even if the bit is five
minutes long it needs to contain 20
jokes within that five minutes
instead of building to just one thing
over the course of a story or something
like that
right so it made me such a better writer
and then i was able to incorporate that
into my stand up
and anyone will tell you just because
you're a good stand-up doesn't mean
you're a good roaster and just because
you're a roaster doesn't mean you're a
good stand-up
i happen to have found that i can use my
skills for both
but if i turn on my roasting brain
it is a little different than me um just
doing stand-up mainly because
i really like i consider myself very
empathetic compassionate kind i really
come from a place of love
so if i don't know that i have the okay
to like roast you guys a little bit i'm
not going to do it
because most people don't want to be
made fun of
yeah it's like their worst nightmare for
me
i [ __ ] love it it made me love myself
hearing of myself be called a billion
different names
has and i can tell you i mean dude i'll
give you some good ones like my very
first roast battle ever
um this one hurt me the most this guy
and this
this guy jason van glass was my first
rose battle said alex looks like
two-face
if two-face was one face
and i stood there and i thought i would
be okay with
it but here's the thing it's not it's
not that you don't know what you look
like
it's the moment when a hundred people
laugh at you yeah yeah because of it
and you're standing on stage being
laughed at
it is such a different beast than what
stand-up is because standard yeah
they're laughing with you you're making
jokes roast battle i tell everyone this
before they do it
you're going to be laughed at and you
need to understand that you're about to
be bullied
and yes you can fight back you can have
redemption
you can rebuttal and get them back even
harder but just understand
you're about to have the [ __ ] guts
pulled out of you
in front of people and i've had that
done on live television
like it is brutal so it made me
really go like okay what who can hurt me
then
who can hurt me right after doing
something like that
i